[Music]
everybody going in wake up early in the
morning press play and let's get it in
cause we rocking with the fighter
[Music]
whose birthday who's birthday birthday
birthday is tomorrow though yeah and
we'll be on the road
we'll be flying a spokane though trying
to spokane now we took
okay spokane cocaine
we were smoking cocaine spokane cocaine
we uh [ __ ] dope you guys surprised me a
little uh
b-day uh dinner last night thanks for
coming out
uh you guys surprisingly thanks for
coming you guys
yeah you guys surprised me with a b day
dinner our spot
man castaway cassaway's the joint
we're on the good side we're on the
inside they didn't treat us like
second-class citizens
so you saw they actually sat us at a
table at first
and the table was little is a bunch of
stuff yeah
and then like you know the uh general
manager whatever he's like no what's
the elon musk of casting yeah elon musk
of castaway the manager yeah took us
over to the evangelistic
shows and he said you know what let's
treat you guys some respect
bringing out wild drinks and he was from
south africa he's from south africa oh
black guy white guy white guy south
africa
okay continue yeah so uh
yeah you saw all south africa was
black not because you know you guys so
much reading today
you know because they had a war okay
south africa
yeah you know what i'm talking about
yeah um
that's our spot though caspar yeah it is
a great food great the food's great man
you met my boy todd feldman yeah todd's
cool todd's dope right
yeah he's like the same size as my
adopted dad they're like the same
[ __ ]
body type and everything really yeah the
hair yeah how does the hell does todd
todd is 46
47. oh okay not in crazy shape yeah
crazy shape
he's he's like a freak as far as like
you know he's all weird about his diet
and [ __ ] oh he is
super weird yeah he i know he was the
only one with that salad
that big-ass salad no one else can sell
it's my birthday man yeah
i didn't cheat that much i did they
brought out that dessert which i didn't
ask for
mm-hmm so i had a few bites of dessert
they brought up a lot of stuff
at home what'd you say we we got a lot
of
random stuff we didn't order from that
manager yeah the indiana jones drink
yeah yeah beauty and the beast drinks it
was like a [ __ ] had a monkey
brain in it
monkey brain yeah it was like disguise
of the monkey brain it was dry eyes
i don't know i'll show you it should be
on nige
yeah joanna might have it on her [ __ ] uh
people just sent me something yep that's
uh
that's it right there that place is
popping too man yeah it was
oh yeah i ripped my jacket it came in
like a
national treasure briefing yeah like
indiana jones
see a monkey brain
came in a box i don't know what it is
but it looked expensive
right yeah i don't know how you would
order that i don't know that's smoking
[ __ ]
but what does that do did it do anything
special to the whiskey i mean the
whisker was really nice i think it was a
japanese whiskey it's really nice
but it wasn't like but like that whole
the whole production yeah the whole
presentation not needed i don't think so
you don't get a kick out of that stuff
you don't get excited i look dope though
i appreciate it i appreciate it it's
really nice of them but
bring my drinks give a [ __ ] about
birthdays anymore
yeah after after 21 who gives a [ __ ]
yeah because 21 yeah i think i think
after the dirty 30
who gives a [ __ ] 30 30. 27 who get what
you're 27.
you're gonna throw a party no you're 28
what are you gonna do throw a [ __ ]
surprise party like the dinner's cool
but other than that i'm all set
no i could just say 30s like something
that's that's you made it to 30. yeah
dirty
it's like you made it yeah that's like
you halfway there to like yeah
i guess it depends where you're at in
life you're 30 dead bro you
what are you celebrating doug of course
you survived to 30. i don't get it i
survived this long being broke i don't
know
but 30 30 i think i think 30 yeah 30 is
good i think 30 30 and then after that
but even in 2021 like dirty 30 doesn't
really exist now it's like true
it's the new thing 20 yeah
yeah before you see 40 you're kind of
comfortable you know what you want in
life 30 you're still
doing i know you are trying to figure
out i guess i don't even remember i
don't remember what i did for my 34th
you don't no i mean what do you do
exactly
like for my kids i might get dope might
be some childhood [ __ ] i've never i
always
got a little sad on my birthday and now
i just don't give a [ __ ]
i don't care yeah if my girl didn't give
anything i wouldn't i'm alright but yeah
yeah
but you're not a gift that's not your
love language oh what
yeah love language ain't your gift your
love language is not gifts it's not
gifts of affirmation
uh what yeah what are you like words of
affirmation uh i like physical touch
physical okay there's two everybody has
two i think it's more physical
hearing it is a little awkward do you
like random acts of kindness
give me a example like uh
say say your girl washed your car
without you knowing
and not be pissed because she probably
got streaks on it
i'd rather hire a professional okay
right she hired a professional so
there's five of them it's random acts of
kindness
yeah physical physical touch acts of
service acts of service uh gift giving
words of affirmation words about words
words do nothing
uh so physical touch is just gonna touch
number one acts of service
after service like this like like it
could be physical it could be
uh like chores like maybe
you think about it from the flip side if
it was joe and it was like her
special day like mother's day and you
did like the laundry you took care of
the kids that would be acts of service
for her
so it depends because i take care of the
kids
quality time quality time is the other
one do you like quality time you like a
little cute
so you like physical touch at quality
time yeah hey dog we're the same person
you do oh i missed chappelle's girl
she's right yes we did
oh yeah i know i thought i was lying
this entire time we really did she's
real
yeah she's really pretty and really nice
yeah she's nice
she's not living in a haunted castle
floral canyon
yeah it is haunted and now i'm balls
deep in laurel canyon i read all the
books on it so i was dropping some facts
i know yeah she knew all of them though
she knew all of it she was like yeah and
we live next year
and i was like you know your place is
haunted she goes oh yeah it's well
documented people were
died in the fight i'm like oh it's super
haunted the uh the houdini estate is in
her area too the [ __ ] magician yep
was he a magician
yeah who didn't he yeah yeah he came out
here to make you big in movies
and they died on uh something what do
you die of i forget didn't he
was something he was doing a stunt right
wasn't he trying to oh something about
punching this was he trying to like
breathe underwater or something
no i think yeah he did get punched in
the stomach punched in his stomach the
guy killed him
you brought your appendix chin that
could have been you oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] that's how he died backstage
encounter
in yeah a walloping jay gordon whitehead
so he got his ass whooped
because uh the guy hit him oh the guy
hit him without him
he sucker punched him yeah he was at
ready because he used to do a thing
where he was always like reading that
punch and this guy like sucker punched
him and
he hadn't seen it but it was but he he
told the guy
because it was like his thing he goes he
knew when
what to do when someone punched him in
the stomach to where
it wouldn't hurt him he'd be like damn
he's only 52. he's only 52. yeah who
yeah houdini lived in hollywood though
right
right up right up that's what i'll say
yeah his estate is like right
you're a girl castle dog boy me and my
girl were pressuring you and your girl
to have kids get married
i know oh my god damn and i was like how
long did you leave
so what your april looked like dog it
was a lot of pressure okay
did you fall did i [ __ ] [ __ ] no
did i fall not only that you also try to
convince them into having kids
that's right yeah trying to convince me
having kids and [ __ ] happens
what happens when you eat sugar just
pressure depression other people yeah
i'll hear
bullying i was like brother such a nice
couple the kids would be so cute and
friendly i know just the friendliest
kids on earth
i know i can't stand some [ __ ] you guys
are very wholesome people too
we are yeah yeah yeah i was telling him
because she she has like
social anxiety so like she's shining i
could tell like
obviously it's a lot because we're all
everyone's close and she's the new bird
yeah yeah so i kept like trying to bring
her into the conversation asking
questions she was she had a blast yeah
she was cool yeah she had a blast did
she like everyone or just some people
she didn't like no she loved everyone
is there some people so you know when
you get in the car you're like that
rebecca man
there's usually that there's always that
my girl was trying to
like when you got in the car about alex
girl yeah
i saved it
my girl tried doing something nice for
me but i think she saw like khloe
kardashian wear it where it's like
you see the top she had on it was like a
business top yeah yeah
like joe blazer and then uh chloe wore
it with like just a brawl
and so my girl was like surprised i was
like you can't wear that today
it was cool like i was like your tits
are hanging out
but i thought it would look nice and
like it it does but it's not
the look we're going uh-huh this is a
family restaurant
if we go to like vegas even then it's
like
that looks like i was explaining to him
like that looks like you're hanging out
nobu you're 44 singles
no blue stuff fantastic place in malibu
oh there's a lot of
young uh divorces that's where you want
to dress that way
well that's what they do because i was
like you're a smart girl like you don't
need
you don't need that attention yeah yeah
like just tits
or masks my girl's not yeah my girl's
not like that
she's not like like your girl dressed
like like mormon
she had a long skirt on my hair oh [ __ ]
might as well have the
[Laughter]
that's like floyd mayweather's the girls
girls they can't look at anybody
no you have to walk in and like when i
was working they'd walk in and
everyone's like god damn they just keep
forward
for real yeah because what if that's
what i do secretly do with my girlfriend
don't look like buddy she's
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i'm not an aggressive guy no he has been
together for two years
two and a half it'll be it'll be i guess
it'd be two and a half because it'll be
three years in september
what's yeah first relationship ever
dude i'm one and only yeah you're doing
yeah probably for your first one though
what you're doing really good for you
you know i kick ass at this [ __ ]
yeah i think i i think i really do it's
only because
but listen it's only because you guys
haven't lived together though
that's a different animal okay i ain't
scared you guys are not
sound like you were last night the way
you asked them how was the conversation
so what's up y'all ain't gonna move in
yeah
what we were saying was overlooking the
valley and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so when we started looking for places in
burbank yeah
i'm like god damn it low-key was kind of
like an interview because at one point
you're like
parents married okay this week
i just seen if she's a stable individual
yeah that's what i was doing
yeah she is yeah she's super stable
super stable super normal
sister yeah see and i listen like i
don't
i don't know and i think i've always
been this way i don't just say yes to
[ __ ] anything
well oh you saying get a relationship
with her yeah like like
her it was different like you know she
was the she was like the first girl that
actually talked to me about like we
actually had a
one of our first conversations was about
like uh personal growth
really oh [ __ ] yeah she's like is that a
journal in your pocket
yeah it is she's like holy [ __ ] that's
hot
that's what did yeah that's what i did
yeah she said you're also like cuz she
came to hollywood and obviously
there's such tools here yeah everyone's
obviously trying because your girl's
pretty everyone's trying to [ __ ] her
yeah she was like you're the first guy
who's like hey you weren't going to hike
yeah
yeah you want to go yeah she's like oh
damn but it was very genuine
yeah you literally was like you
literally were working for a workout
partner
yeah well because i was like hey my
buddy and i you know we go
we go hike this spot would you like to
come that's all i said
i didn't have like any intentions like
that didn't come
just so happened you just it just
happened yeah you know i was just
inviting her and you know because i was
like oh she's
she's really cool and then we just
started hanging out a lot more and
you know then i kissed her on the
forehead and she laughed oh yeah
no it's not weird well it's not yeah
that's sacred it shows a lot about me
yeah i'm a good guy hashtag good guy
that's that good guy how long have you
and stevie been dating cat um
he and i started dating in august
before we told anybody and then you guys
found out like what october
no i found out in august oh see yeah
first of all yeah yeah
[Laughter]
if you [ __ ] this up i will slap your big
dick around
okay with that and rip your homer tattoo
off over that
bruh what do you guys think you've got a
homer's head too no yeah homer's
basically his dick yeah it's like homer
looking at it going
it's the best tattoo dude it's the
funniest
oh
did you get that in prison he's like nah
man like i feel like that's a prison
dude
i wanted four years in here three left
yo [ __ ] it dude
i mean if you had a big dingling with
you i mean i don't know what you're
packing
not to say you lose stevie's is bigger
mine but not by much i gotta be honest
it makes me feel wow what's up
i got a house right here
thicker you know like he's carrying that
bazooka i got that
[ __ ] bazooka i get that oozy but if
together i was like hey steve you got to
go in the [ __ ] stall oh not me
urinals for me oh so that's a gift for
going to [ __ ] not me i go next
stephen you're like
yeah that big
i want a picture of the tattoo artist
who was trying to tattoo that at home
and that dick was right they're saying
tattoo artists do someone's like ass
the girls are both both both no
they're just like they're dead serious
about their job just like
like the korean suit that was you know i
was watching the dock on vice about this
oh yeah like the japanese style like
yeah but the main guy they flew out from
korean right
yeah he's korean and he's in san jose or
san francisco yeah yeah we have a
four-year waiting list
but he does or you're waiting for your
waiting list he's like the best in the
world
he does full body hey they've been
working on this white dude
they've been working on this white dude
big hairy white dude
but he's getting his ass done they're
literally like all up in the booty hole
what's the guy's name i couldn't tell
you is that netflix oh vice
vice if he's from san jose it might be
he's not from there he works out of that
yeah works out of there dr wu there's
money
no stop talking from la doctor who's
done all crystallized stuff
and whitney cummings not dr wu doctor
wu's more
fine line like like real detailed
smaller stuff
this dude is a big deal sure if you
typed in like
i'm pretty sure he's japanese man he's
typing top japanese
uh tattoo art because that's a japanese
style tattoo
though like that full background here's
what they're saying that's weird too on
that
um yoshi there is taki horror target
where no you see the america's biggest
japanese tattoo artist
yep that's him he has a four-year weight
yeah i mean my girl looked it up because
i was like
i told my girls hey i get some [ __ ] oh
state of grace this is a huge tattoo
spot in san jose
no in little tokyo it's a big deal right
it's a wreath
it's one of those things where like
people will go in hang out and look at
artwork and see if they could get uh
an appointment with them before it's
four years yeah i know
my girl i was like i'd love to get some
work by him we look look at that oh
that's
so [ __ ] dope isn't that dope yeah so
he's like
there he is he's the head one harito he
only had one
horrito this is like the tattoo culture
in san jose everyone wants something
like this
yes you have to take your shoes off and
[ __ ] yeah variation
he's very ocd very asian that's asian
what is that
with asian culture just taking your
shirt taking your shoes off is
just like a sign of respect because you
don't want to like track dirt or
anything inside
it makes a lot of sense it really does
walk around the streets all day now i
don't do it but
like when people ask me i'm like that
makes sense yeah and i should probably
do it too
is isn't that the most painful way to
get a tattoo that the stick
yeah it's pretty painful what's the
other one is it is it polynesian
polynesian also uses the stick or they
do like the single needle where they
hammer it down
there'd be a saucer chick-fil-a but not
the same huh what
you said that's chick-fil-a hey um
because you said pollinator
hey so why is that shovel like sticking
it's just a traditional way of doing
testing scraping it but it's like that's
how
you do it everyone just do it back in
the day yeah indians everybody's like a
screwdriver and he's just like sticking
them with a screwdriver that's how
tattoos were done back in the day
but polynesia they have a hammer yeah
it's like a little stick polynesians do
it filipinos do it a lot of islanders
that's their way of doing oh yeah the
rock has that
rihanna has her hand tattoo done in that
process it's really really nice
how good is this guy four four year
weightless tattoos are painful as [ __ ]
very expensive too
oh i bet that guy's super expensive
that's funny one guy they did his whole
back
in front and he said it was 50 hours
my girl's like oh that's not bad that's
like a week and like if you think he got
all that done
that's probably a year spread out yeah
something
i see why there's a fort that's [ __ ]
see my cheeks done like that
damn you want them you want to be
cheeked up like that see what's nice
about that is if you have a flat ass no
one would ever know
no but they were saying in this uh like
mini documentary on vice
with the japanese that in japan it's
frowned upon
like japanese yeah japanese culture
looks down oh yeah
the yokuza which is their mafia they you
can tell yakuza because they have tat
from their neck
throughout the end they look sick they
look similar with what you said about uh
italians looking down on the mafia
yeah and not liking it yeah but even the
tattoo culture like america now
definitely appreciates tattooing more
than they did in the 90s oh yeah yeah
but and they're saying in japan it's
super frowned upon even in general like
they don't [ __ ] with it yeah
they don't think it's creative they
don't think it's dope like it's not
their thing
damn so they come here and make bank
because we're like hell yeah [ __ ]
tattoo my [ __ ]
i'm getting happy written in japanese
and [ __ ] yeah we have no idea what it
says
yeah i have a dope uh what does it say
the guy who did it from red dragon and i
think colorado springs in colorado
but it's like this dope like geisha mask
so mr ward off like evil spirits
i don't know my sister has a tattoo as
well geisha now he's like some
i don't know it's in chinese and it goes
it should say passionate
it's true i don't know what mine should
i say sweet and sour
i've you know i i forget what monk says
you don't i
i really i think i don't know what's the
geisha mask
it's like like a demonic like it's kind
of yeah it's like a demonic
mask and it's supposed to war off evil
that's the cool thing about um
asian tattoos is a lot of them mean
something or it's supposed to like
they have a real dope meaning like mulan
it all kind of has like its own
symbology
let's take a little break from the
fighter and the kids shenanigan with my
boys because today's episode
is brought to you by my favorite kratom
on the planet
from the kratom experts at super
speciosa that's right if you've never
heard of kratom
it's a herbal supplement kind of like
cbd but instead of coming from the can i
was
plant something closer to a coffee tree
people use kratom every day
me and chin uh and i use it to get my
mind right for any show
any podcast any tv gig any stand up i'm
drenched in kratom through my veins i
love it but here's the problem
it's the wild west of kratom out there
man it's the wild wild
west so you got to trust who you get it
from and that's why
i can only recommend super speciosa to
you
and they're also giving you guys twenty
percent off so go to
get super leaf dot com slash fighter
that's get super l e
a f dot com slash fighter enter promo
code fighter for 20
off that's getsuperleaf.com promo code
fighter
listen kids with today's low interest
rates
it's a great time to refinance your
student loans
earnest offers low rate student loan
refinancing
and you can check your rate risk-free in
just two minutes with earnest
you can get flexible payments you can
pay them uh pick your loan term actually
by refinancing you can reduce your loan
terms save money combine multiple loans
into one simple monthly payment and if
you have any questions you can even talk
to a real human
at earnest for help isn't it time you
stop feeling overwhelmed by your student
debt
yep let's do it kids earnest is offering
you guys a hundred dollar cash
bonus when you refinance your student
debt at earnest.com
fighter terms conditions apply uh now
ernest is giving you guys 100
bonus refinancing your student loan at
earnest.com fighter
terms and conditions apply visit
earnest.com for more details
terms conditions apply keep telling me
that earnest student loan refinance is
made by
earnest operations llc nmls number one
two zero four nine one seven california
financing law license number six zero
five four seven eight eight
303 second street suite 401 north san
francisco california 94107
visit earnest.com licenses for full list
of licenses
again that is earnest.com fighter
oh [ __ ] you see the like the devil on
the right that's oh no you see the guy
with the horns the black and white the
bottom row far right chin
far right yeah that one see the guy with
the horns oh yeah
that's [ __ ] sick you're not seeing
anything his tongue is out and he's like
breathing don't be looking at your body
oh i
encouragement man i know hey i give you
positive encouragement
you did feel my arms before we started
shooting yeah i was like damn boys
getting big
and he getting big appreciation bigger
you're getting bigger
no your your chest my chest hit them
chest
i can finally do it now it felt good i'm
surprised you don't get something like
this that'd be sick man i think once i
start
like if i get one i'm gonna still crazy
well yeah yeah
go crazy yeah [ __ ] it bubba you're 40
something i know
like that to me now or never the way i
see it too when the older you get like
when you're 50 it's like yeah you know
like people
i thought 40s was the new 20s though yes
it is
you don't start your full body tap when
you're 50. but your tattoos look nicer
but like
look at people get tattoos when they're
younger when they get older it just
starts to fade
i'll have like fresh tattoos around 40
something i think that'd be difficult
i've done ufc fights in my tats they
look [ __ ] fresh
i
me and my teammates got it done and then
i fought two weeks later that was a bad
idea
for the ones on my arm i'm getting my
legs sleeved up in
austin oh boy's coming down yeah yeah
jesse jesse
you're getting the whole thing i didn't
want to tell the group because then
justin's like oh i'm gonna hit him
like bro he's finishing a sleeve on my
leg there ain't gonna be other room dog
maybe late at night hey he loves
tattooing me we're we're like the only
ones that get the tattoos
oh wait jay jay always coming coming
with you like let me get this off let me
get this stop source
i'm like since when are you in the tower
wait what the [ __ ] no you
talking about the original
tattoo i'm like yeah because i've sold
out every show i've ever done
he was like homage to texas he's like oh
okay
then he came back like 20 minutes i was
like jay what'd you get let me get a
compass
it's just everyone's getting it does
look really good on them though that's
hard
racing's flags black and obviously yeah
i'll get the racing i'll probably add
racing
to my leg you should get a compass you
guys do you guys have brother tattoos oh
yeah we have a bunch
of same oh they got the little v they
got the we have the v we have the
the the we come like the spade the club
oh yeah yeah i saw that though we have
the horseshoe with chin
okay oh cause you sold out uh i hold up
about dublin chill want to get on his
neck i still should have got a candy i
still want to get a
uh well let's relax a little i still uh
uh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i would never get anything from kansas
tattoo don't do that uh what about
what oh japan's like shoes big ass
special there in like chief stadium i
might get something
get patrick holmes right on your back
just [ __ ]
nikoi christian nikoi
oh old school running back for the
chiefs oh i don't know that yeah
old school dad one of them pacific you
wouldn't know
azuza azuza not even d1 is it no
but he came out of there so people
people can come out of yeah
oh really it's tough enough to make it a
d1 but there's a few exceptions because
i was like do those scouts go to those
schools and check out
they don't even know unless you're like
like the best of the best of all time
from that school they might give you an
invite
would they even question like why is he
here if he's like the better like
[ __ ] happens oh really [ __ ] happens what
is it a lot of uh
they might get overlooked had injuries
there's academics
oh like when we were watching the uh my
college chance you
oh yeah they they got alex college on uh
is it called chance you oh
the one where they do in l.a yeah i
watched two episodes like this
is [ __ ] is that the college you went
to yeah well it was so funny because
everybody was literally telling me like
hey we found alex scott i said
that's my school baby i'm not how about
hey how about the one the one
how about the one review goes the new
season of last chance you is so cringe
oh really you said it's bad santa i
thought it was dope
we were watching it did you see the
original no with the white coach
oh dude he was good oh my god that
sounds like coaching
that sound like the playback it was oh
east los angeles uh community college
that's what it was
he said east los angeles state tax state
tech
technical school devry university
we graduate on thetuesday.org you
graduate on a tuesday
the horns come on go to college man what
you doing
it's unreal it's so [ __ ] good the
original is it
is it a high school or a college yeah
it's a juco where you call it
all these rejects come from and it's the
number one hey we're not rejects at
jucos
yeah a little bit it's yeah come on that
was [ __ ] badass
yeah i made it to louisville right yeah
yeah
oh yeah these guys don't really go to
university they try
some of them do and then you somebody
just realized they're complete f there's
re
like some of them should like one kid
was like the star at florida state
recruit
was just a total [ __ ] up so he can't
play the you know he gets kicked out so
he ends up at
you know the last chance you school and
like kansas
that's what happened to that kid he
played at uh penn state kent state got
here
penn state he got hurt and he started he
started smoking a lot or whatever
yep and then he went back down told you
the story before
all of them have the same story and then
and then on i thought i was hearing
something new
every single juco guy has the same story
they're all [ __ ] up
whether they don't do grades or whatever
or they're just stupid
and then they get like uh the one main
guy and last chance you who
everybody loved he came from like a
rough background everyone cheered for
him
he got invited or he yeah he got invited
to play for the oakland raiders so then
he was on
hard knocks when the raiders were john
gruden
and john gruden like he has like this
injury and he's like babying it
and uh he's there for like two days and
they're in the office and grooms like
cut his ass we don't need him he's
[ __ ] terrible
and then he gets caught literally the
next day damn it's so cut throat huh
nfl's so cut though oh like we don't
[ __ ] need him cut that guy
you know ah man the last chance you guy
damn the other [ __ ]
sean kim went to my he's an alumni at
the juco i went to in texas
yeah a lot of i mean jon jones went to
juco like there's there's a reason why
you go to juco
yeah yeah but you're so talented yeah
it's nothing that's why i went it's
north dakota state is that a
no no no no that's a big school why not
watch all gonna say uh
you almost went there come on g i'm
riding with you thank you
you're almost watching carson wins
carson wins yeah
this year who is the quarterback the
black kid oh yeah
but he was the first guy from uh they're
ballers like they dominate their
division i think they might be one
double a
but big time football for that division
okay so when you went to the
like when you went to the bills they
gave you a contract or they're just like
you sign a contract you sign a cut it's
not a contract
it's not really a contract or it is but
it's you know it might it might as well
be so
like okay bring this job you're gonna be
on our team this is this is your
contract you're basically signing away
all your name and likeness and
if you get injured like you know like
yeah i'm not going to give you like
the first round drive so they give you
like 10 million dollar deal no no no no
no i think i should pay them
and and they took my journal i want to
keep my jersey like nah [ __ ]
i was like if i could just hit that i
could just go home with a hat i'd be
stoked
they gave me damn it's that cutthroat
yeah man damn
you gotta watch last chance the original
the original it's tuesday i watched the
original
theo had the coach and i talked to the
coach we're gonna have him fighting the
kid
because the coach is born and raised a
white dude from compton and he's like
let's bring him in he was like the
all-time well not now
because he had some [ __ ] go down he got
fired oh because they actually had a
german kid on the team
and he said i'm your hitler he was i'm
gonna you do what i say i'm your hitler
and then that kid posted it on social
media got fired man
wait what but the coach is one of those
guys like he's from compton
so he acts real ghetto yeah he's pure
entertainment oh really but he's already
gotta watch he's a really really good
coach so he's first last
first two seasons first two seasons
because he's somewhere and then he
leaves there
i think he and then goes another one but
he's such a character
he talks so much [ __ ] to the kids but he
relates to him because he came from the
street
and it was the baller quarterback damn
so he released oh so this is for
football oh yeah yeah because this one
is basketball
oh yeah this is what this is about it's
all i'm telling you that's
horrible yeah i think that ruined the
series oh dude basketball
yeah you got to watch the football one
it's so good
i can't wait why do from college
it's so frustrating too because the kids
like they're like man
if you just go to class you're going to
have you have offers from alabama
florida state
penn state okay miss his class i mean
like and then this coach
like knocks on the dorm room like dude
what are you doing yeah he's like i'm
just tired manny's like dude
all you have the teacher said she will
pass you all you to do is show up
and you have a full ride to florida
state and he misses you right you know
they were about to do that with me
like self-sabotage no um when i switched
high schools
and they were they wanted me to play
football or whatever
and they were like we'll help you
[ __ ] graduate well because i i didn't
graduate on time
eat a dick what's up what's on your mind
oh no you got something to say
you said play football they didn't want
me to bro i was just fans
like running back yeah i was just fast i
don't look
what i'm saying is i'm not i would never
say i'm a [ __ ]
football player yeah yeah yeah bro i
know no you can't catch well i can't i
can't
[ __ ] i can't i played football for 14
years at a high level you could probably
play football
yeah because you're athletic be real
explosive
bruh i'm telling you real you're pretty
nice unless we have crossroads who's
that
uh my mother's dog there's a girl who's
the girl behind shout out to toby shout
out to derek
who's that black guy that's derek uh
green from the band's cell photo
oh that's hard oh that's yeah some fan
did that but that's not it
oh oh i was at the view view that view
view my girl still had the
titties out you should see what she
wanted to wear before i'm like we can't
we can't do that oh
was that [ __ ] dessert
[Music]
yeah i cheated on my diet um yeah we i
had a little bit we had a little bit i
had a couple fries too
um no
go back hey where the [ __ ] it go
you just posted post it like that you
posted the end of the video you never
[ __ ] up right
oh [ __ ] oh you can see what i said
let that be me
exactly talk [ __ ] on me i deserve it i
know i [ __ ] up right
now doggy you almost had a hundred
thousand followers mm-hmm oh yeah
dude let's do a love is tight giveaway
you hit a hundred thousand
oh this is what we do it's a hundred
thousand
he will randomly pick one of his new
followers and give you
uh free merch free yeah i'll give you a
whole love is tight
uh catalog catalog like like catalog i
mean like collections three pieces
three pieces three or four pieces yeah
collection as soon as he hits 100k
he's almost there he's about ten
thousand almost close to 100k
a honey hey but as i was saying listen
i don't think i could have [ __ ]
played football listen i tried to play
flag football and [ __ ] when i was
younger i tried
i gave it a [ __ ] shot okay
[ __ ] i gotta catch this ball
in the air yeah huh yeah it's tough you
throw this ball like
and like from a distance yeah and that
ball high as [ __ ] in the air
hand hand and eye coordination and night
coronation i can run
okay yeah yeah we race yeah the thing
about it if you're running back
and we just hand you the ball then you
just got to run through the hole with
your thick ass
oh that's it yeah oh i did call you
jerome better than the podcast the boss
who called me jerome built like the bus
oh that's the guy from the steelers yeah
i'm not built like him you have the
exact same body uh
i think i used to yeah but when i would
before we started the workouts i did
true we are losing weight you know we
still don't do i
still don't get [ __ ] 200. we
still don't look like mark we don't look
like mark
i don't know anybody
haters will say we're not here i'm like
and
at first i was like i was like that's
funny like every time
hella hella mark harvey yeah that's it
right there
everything's that haters will say i
think he
was like this
hey this will say i know i was being
photographed but actually
he's 240 pounds 240. and his
legs are jacked how tall is he that's
all he's doing
six three is he six three six two six
three
he's just a little shorter than you he's
probably six three cause i'm six four
okay yeah he's pro he's probably six
three just a beast of a man
yeah and that's on a regular day haters
would say this caption is random
obscured enough
he's funny man he is funny dude
damn damn i want my pecs to look like
that bro yeah
he got him man he got some pegs man yeah
he's an interesting looking dude
i know people and people at the gym are
like that one dude was like hey man
where fabio at because he he went he's
walking
yeah we got there first that black guy's
like man where the [ __ ] [ __ ]
pretty [ __ ] yeah i said
he didn't give a [ __ ] about brendan
oh that's one of mark's commercials bro
yeah he be getting that commercial work
too
you're in for a brutal waiting
oh god he's so funny he reminds me of
ben stiller from dodge ball
the owner of uh global gym oh
yeah guy he huge he shred it
dude he's so shredded and how are you
all working
if he has if he's like say
he's that he's doing 315 he wants to get
10. oh that [ __ ] gonna get
he's getting 10. strong strong right
strong strong even if like he
like if he struggles at like say he
struggles but he looks yeah right
say he struggles at six oh that
[ __ ] is still gonna get ten yeah
he's gonna get ten
i always i was always curious how they
like six and then they pushed the last
four
bro cuz your arms are shaking and you
got to breathe
like he's really good with his technique
technique is where's that his technique
is insane he's also uh
california northern uh oh yeah what do
you think one no 2000 wrestling champ
yeah he's a wrestling champion yeah yeah
high school high school wrestling
california restaurant 2001 2001
where he shouted it out we were just i
was like what
he goes there doesn't that matter you
know it doesn't i said
not that cif wrestling champions
just marion county right wouldn't he
shout out after i said that he just
finished hitting he got excited
because well bradley was talking about
jiu jitsu or something like that yeah me
and bradley are talking about uh going
yeah grappling together you should get
into grappling you'd probably be good at
that
oh grappling yeah once i get the new gym
space there's mats there we'll be able
to grapple like
grapplers yeah you can be someone can
meet you at 200. yeah real soon
all right well you know i was at 10th
planet you were oh yeah
before kobe before covert yeah you was
doing a little bit did you did you like
it
yeah you know see you know what listen i
did it because
rogan was like man yeah oh you went to
10th planet yeah
it was like
that's what he said he said the same for
you but i'm trying to get in shape and
like just do
ain't the way to go it just yeah yeah
yeah it's just a long
time because rogan was like he goes man
you'll be really good at it because like
you know like you were cheerleading and
being able to do all the flips and all
that stuff and
which he's probably right you know what
i mean but like i'd rather
i think i think there's a it takes a
level like of a mentality
yeah for a person to do that [ __ ] if
roman pushes
someone to do a podcast or jitsu or the
sauna one more time
[ __ ] freak out asana it ain't for
everybody man for everybody i'm like bro
he was [ __ ] don't get wrong i i had a
good time
you know what i mean but it's just not i
just don't think
it's a commitment that it's a community
it's too much time
and at the time i was doing it bro i had
no money i wasn't going
there's a lot of money to pay for it i
didn't have a car yeah so it was like in
in the one i was like
it was just you went to the one downtown
or in west hollywood uh
no wouldn't even know there's one in uh
bird bank too right no not in burbank
glendale maybe like
on the way to like beverly hills or
something like that i can't remember i
think that's the
culver city maybe something like that i
can't remember exactly
but uh yeah it was just a lot it was
like bro i can't i was like this is a
lot of money
i was like bro i was like i'd rather
just focus all on stand up right now
it's just it just didn't make make any
sense you know but he's like yeah man
get you in there you know start
going you know start rolling around and
[ __ ] and then do what you have he had me
hyped
i'm not going to laugh you called me i'm
like
i was like put your energy in something
else it was so funny uh
after one of the times i i had to go
drive to brea to go do uh
shows with you yeah i was all [ __ ] up
tired i'm like damn this [ __ ]
that's it's exhausting i always thought
hill does a lot of it now in
nashville yeah that's what i'm saying
you'll be getting beat up by girls
listen
i'll i'll it's like if i want to do
something outside of comedy like maybe
dayboarding
guitar do something you know enjoy yeah
i enjoy playing the game
i enjoy working out like that's that's
different you know what i mean
like that doesn't it all work that huh
yeah i'm with it it's tough i i always
find it fascinating when uh strike
the judiciary guy rollers are or mma
fighters they come to wild card
and they land they train with freddie
roach yeah they get in there with the
boxer
and uh their technique is very different
because they got to worry about
everything in mma and then boxing yeah
your man your man ben
is uh uh training with freddy ben oh
that's right yeah yeah yeah that's why
he's out here downstairs oh
g got knocked out by him but he's a good
fighter but they they was in there
working
was he still fighting yeah he's still
going it's over
but yeah when his ship have sailed
yeah it's just over oh he's just older
he's 34 35 no he's on that
yes he's mine isn't he i think how long
is it troubling that's
38. god damn
yeah yeah like canelo won't give him a
rebate so i don't know
they did three they did three times
didn't have two two he wants a third and
canelo has no interest in it he wants
but why but what why would he definitely
want the first one
yeah i get i agree with you he won you
think triple g one yeah sure
yeah yeah canelo was the marketing guy
so of course you're gonna
it's more money was older yeah i know he
says his big drama show
like it's a tough sell oh got it
yeah everyone has their time
cap jim what are you guys doing this
weekend
nothing really i don't have anything
planned stevie's out of town with you
guys
i think i'm just gonna hang out get my
nails done take pictures of my feet
yeah make make money yeah with that
money
make that money are you coming to miami
with us
i mean you and steve are going to miami
and we won't see you guys
let's be real i don't know i mean that's
the true [ __ ]
that's the last one of you take me
around and take photos of me yeah
it's a rider for you get them toes and
get them toes in the sand
yeah get those toes in a beat yeah but
stevie has that app
toro where you know instead of rental
cars you can just people
don't drop it off cars in miami those
cars are lit
cheap too we found a big-ass hummer
lifted hummers
gladiator there's a bunch of lambos and
[ __ ] you can wrap for cheap
like two three hundred dollars i'm not
getting into no lambo no more
not for you two [ __ ] small
yeah he agreed he was driving he was
going like
what's this how fast were you going
probably 80 80 80 you know but the top
down still
like yeah bro i'm like why do you do
that why do you grab the driver like
that's not gonna
distract him at all i don't know cause
it's just like [ __ ] bruh
first instinct what are you gonna do
kill some fish uh no i'm killing fish no
we're not killing fish
i'm gonna go to oh they call it fishing
fishing yeah no
just going to our friend's house over
the weekend we're gonna do our taxes oh
my god
i [ __ ] hate chips that's true we're
actually gonna just drink and party but
do our taxes because our friend she's a
she's an accountant she knows how to you
know you can do some exe again do you do
your time not this weekend man you're
not gonna
see it i gotta recover oh yeah you can't
take no drugs
but the ones they gave you they're all
done oh they're all done
you finished you know i did it like you
were supposed to do it though so within
three four days they're gone yeah take
some adderall call it turbo tax
i don't get that but i mean that's how
they're wrong yeah yeah
yeah it's where you do your own taxes
though chin you don't want to hire
somebody i do the same no she's a
she's a pro yeah she
we're gonna do our friend's house she's
the accountant she's a professional
accountant
so she just does all of her friends at
the same time okay and we just chill and
hang out we work and you guys getting
hammered pretty much
yeah oh yeah i didn't know that
chappelle oh oh you uh
oh you know taxes i know mine do you
bruh it's pretty funny right off
i gotta go away for a little bit man not
his hair blonde
demolition i got to do demolition pull
up wesley sides from demolition man yeah
all right that's what i was talking
about doing
that blonde but then i would have to cut
my hair to get rid of it huh
yeah yeah but this one yeah that one
it's almost that's not even blonde
that's like a orange honey yeah
it is kind of orange that's like blonde
before you tone it properly yeah
look at that picture right there bro if
i don't recreate that [ __ ]
that would be so sick
but i just had this overall time overall
i gotta re-watch that movie that's a
great movie
yeah he was a problem in that movie
such a beast that does dennis rodman he
was killing on the blade series too dude
he did three he crushed the blade too
now they got a new one coming out
they do yeah without him though oh
they did one ryan reynolds oh no ryan
reynolds was in that one
or sorry he was just on three that's
he got jacked for that oh you told me i
got to watch deadpool
[ __ ] yeah you said i was like you and i
don't like like you
like i like like the dark knight like
the realistic like i don't like avengers
and
guarding the galaxies even though i
heard it's great but uh
deadpool's funny deadpool is very good
it's well done got nominated for oscar
the first one and he wrote it he tried
to sell it to marvel for years
i liked him you know what happened when
they didn't pick it up
he uh paid for a trailer so he could
pitch it to
producers and they didn't greenlight it
so what he did
well not he but somebody who had the
footage leaked it online
there was so uh much positive feedback
that they ended up making the movie
that's how he did it and that's one of
their biggest franchises yeah
one's dope all right i gotta watch i
gotta watch it gina carano is in it
i don't know who that is but she's the
one who got uh
fired from disney for the coveted ship
pokemon oh the nazi
brad pitt is in it very shortly brad
pitt's in it it's a great and he's funny
dude
very funny ryan reynolds has great
comedic timing he's a monster didn't he
do a
a green lantern movie as well yeah yeah
that wasn't they didn't do too great
right he did
no yeah these deadpools crush it i got i
got to check it out
yeah you think i like it though yeah i
guarantee it i think you'd love it
especially
yeah yeah it's good well i like ryan
reynolds so
i respect it yeah he's so funny speaking
of dark knight they got the new batman
uh robert patterson is the new one
twilight dude yeah he's the same chin as
the comic books but that's about
it he's a really good actor he's a great
is he though hold on uh is that the let
me see the trailer
trailer yes fans won't be able to see it
no
he didn't get ben affleck jackie but
well he was a natural like ectomorph
like like you know skinny guy
yeah i feel like yeah so he was just
dude you know how many steroids i'd get
on if they told me to be
batman i've been covert hit so i mean on
oh they already have a trailer for it oh
yeah it's hard too
the joker's in it right nice there's
letters in it it's it's the
oh yeah oh he's in it and the penguins
in it and what the
board the riddler the riddler you're the
you're the first person i've heard say
they like
jared leto's joker love them people are
[ __ ] haters
the zebra was to create
insurance to be in black and white no
gray area the zebra is the nation's
leading insurance comparison site
for car and home insurance they can help
you save money right now it's so damn
easy
go to the zebra.com answer a few quick
questions compare accurate insurance
quotes
free the zebra protects your personal
information make sure there's no hidden
fees all right
you can secure your insurance from the
zebra.com
or over the phone from one of their
licensed insurance agents
with the states reopening people back on
the road the zebra is committed to
making sure
you and the fam are covered how much
money can you save on car
or home insurance visit the zebra.com
fighter that's t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a-dot-com
fighter for insurance in black and white
this episode is sponsored by bluetooth
bluetooth is making waves bringing more
confidence to the sac
all right bluetooth is a unique online
service that delivers
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable form
for a fraction of the cost bluetooth uh
tablets combat all forms of erectile
dysfunction and can help men gain extra
confidence
in the bedroom when it's time to perform
bluetooth is the online prescription
service
no visit the doctor's office no awkward
conversations we got you covered no
waiting line at the pharmacy shifts
right to your door discreet little
package
the process is so damn easy sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days it's all done
online all right the tablets are made in
the u.s
of a prepare and ship direct so it's
cheaper than the pharmacy so
if this sounds like something you could
use in the sack with your lady or your
dude whatever you're into
visit bluechew.com for more details
important safety information
and you can try blue chew free when you
use the promo code fighter at checkout
just pay five dollar shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code fighter to
receive your first month
free oh have you heard about spiderman
three where all three spidermans are
coming back yeah
that batman looked all right what luke's
all right
i i do feel like i have a preference for
the christian bale stuff mm-hmm
christian you like christian bells that
batman or yeah he's great batman
i love him all his movies are great yeah
he's a great actor but yeah i mean
i didn't like his voice still yeah but
other than that
i thought it was great yeah it was just
but he had to know that
yeah it sounded so stupid
but he talked normal when he was
bruising yeah it was so stupid oh
he has to do that though i don't know i
think it's just just weird yeah yeah
interesting characters but the music in
that movie too the sound effects
the way it looked it was christian right
yeah
yep okay so a photo of lenny
kravitz is going viral because he is 56
and looks like this
he's 56 56 damn
right that is gonna be us zoe kravitz's
dad and she is the new catwoman for that
batman wow
good for her and his body right look at
him i know
jesus looks like a shredded predator
mm-hmm he's it means health
yep well he looks better than the
regular picture than himself
doesn't he live in like brazil or
something like that who knows
i feel like it's hawaii like an island
yeah yeah island somewhere when his dick
popped out
yeah and it was pizza it was it was all
flopping around
what it did yeah yeah leather pants
no underwear yeah
that thing was hanging damn that thing
was so sweaty
he's just playing the guitar and he was
like whoa yep he didn't give a [ __ ]
did i know that he's a legend they said
he was hanging out with j.lo a little
bit
we should see that yeah damn j-lo
yes you know how to move on yeah look at
that dick
the girl in the back's like uh
everyone
[Laughter]
why'd he go no undies though what was he
thinking you can't wear no underwear
leather pants though you'll be swimming
that dick is popping
that's something too yeah that thing's
nothing big
why is lauren's fish burning in the
background morpheus
oh [ __ ] maurice blooper
damn how long did he rock out with his
[ __ ] out like that
that's it you got to feel that breeze
though you have never
oh he might be in the moment sweaty i've
ripped my leather on the stage
i've ripped my pants oh you fell you
[ __ ] you feel like
oh i knew no i knew i i heard them like
ah goddammit
where are you
[Laughter]
i know imagine that's your dad like god
damn it
he's doing a crabby steven tyler texted
him
dude no under her end pairs [ __ ] me he
never showed me that [ __ ]
[ __ ] wait his ding ling pierced mm-hmm
yeah like on the top or something
they called what they called the prince
albert prince albert oh that's what they
call it yeah
why why priscilla i don't know that's a
weird nickname it's a weird [ __ ]
nickname there's a wrestler named prince
albert
[Laughter]
he's just rocking
he's trying to rock out with this [ __ ]
out i mean
why is it called
to assist the hams jones with the
relatively tight trousers oh so he
wanted to seem like he was
that thing thing that droopy oh that's
why i called prince albert that's cool
i guess so ganks are doing that back
then
damn right just dig out on stage
okay i think a while ago we have talked
about that teenager who hacked a bunch
of twitter accounts
asking for bitcoin so he hacked uh
bidens
elons a bunch of people jeff bezos right
mm-hmm and he was asking for
people to uh buy him bitcoin in return
he would double their money for half an
hour
so like if let's say i bought him 100
worth of bitcoin he would return to me
200 so a lot of people did that trying
to get in
during that half an hour period he ended
up getting over a hundred thousand
dollars in bitcoin before it was stopped
he was recently sentenced to three years
but he has 229 days
already served because he was uh
already in holding or something and
holding yeah oh so they counted that
yesterday he was just a kid
yeah he was 17 when it happened now he's
18 right but now he's an adult when he's
saying what federal uh yes federal yeah
you got affairs and
talking about so he's probably doing
he's probably not in the crazy
and they probably yeah especially
because he's so young
yeah they're better yeah he's smart as
hell though yeah very
very smart that's the thing a lot of
these teenagers now are really good at
computers and technology that it seems
like they're just hacking
man these kids are learning how to like
like have you heard of coding yeah
coding
yeah i don't know what it entails at all
but i know like it's like programming
for uh computer websites yeah websites
apps oh just anything yeah
next one yeah yes here we go okay
so a woman in pennsylvania is
actually arrested because she's trying
to terrorize
teenagers and their parents who are a
part of her daughter's cheer team
she's trying to make like intimidate
these uh
cheerleaders from dropping out and from
competing in competition so her daughter
has more
uh like performance time you know and
she's doing
[Applause]
no she's not keto um but she
actually used deep fake technology to
put faces of these teenagers onto like
photos of other people smoking drinking
or even nude
and then she sent it to them saying like
if you don't
drop out i'm gonna send these out or i'm
gonna report you
what a [ __ ] idiot yeah yo like those
hey do they have
sheer samples or no no i know yeah i
want to see you
these are underrated it's just really
bad there's like a slight lag and
everything yeah no chair moms are
[ __ ] nuts about like wanting their
kid
to like shine dan's mom's a lifetime
they're so serious oh yeah
yeah dance moms yeah same [ __ ] they're
literally moms compete
hey how many of them uh cheer moms when
you're teaching those kids try to get a
hold of that
chocolate stick what i'm not kissing too
you know i'm sure a couple of moms were
looking there liking
hey right you leave me alone a little
thicker hershey i wasn't thick back then
i was in shape i was in shape yeah i'm
sure
did you just train their kids bro look
at that mom
like if i could just give me some
chapelle
i'm bringing them extra babies
thirsty for it and the competitor they
were
yeah nah man they're a couple private
they're good people
so this is another high school one where
a high school principal
uh has a 17 year old daughter who goes
to the school that she
is the principal of they actually caught
the mother and daughter hacking into
students accounts so the daughter would
win homecoming queens these [ __ ]
people
but also i like how the police did a
whole investigation right
you could be focusing on than this
[ __ ] lady that's true i just want my
daughter to be [ __ ] prom queen
too and what happens to them i guess
she's getting arrested for hacking into
the system okay listen all that for
homecoming
queen what the [ __ ] listen to grades
get me to college yeah great [ __ ] homie
yeah
[ __ ] that [ __ ] man that's just for the
grandma yeah that's right listen you're
a parent
yeah right you love your kids yeah
would you do anything it's so
embarrassing
to think like oh man my my kid deserves
this
i'm gonna [ __ ] hack into this
like i get it you love your kids and
[ __ ] i get it
but like i mean if my kid is not
homecoming
queen then [ __ ] it you suck i mean i'm
not saying you suck both of them you
just lost
yeah take the [ __ ] l but like but
even homecoming king
or queen like what's it do but also yeah
who gives a [ __ ] cares
i wonder if your daughter was popular at
all
because what if it's just like some like
some shy like nerdy girl who like didn't
get any attention then suddenly she's
like homecoming
the whole school
hold on now let's recap the votes she's
like the worst looking one
debbie y'all sure
i just see them announcing it just like
is even the principal's like
i don't know so bad before your
homecoming queen is
damn wait is this right did you guys get
voted for homecoming or problem
i hated everybody my sister was promised
that was too crazy
cat no never chin no
did you you seem like i got voted for uh
[Applause]
no i was like
and he knew he was gonna
[Applause]
hey i appreciate it i appreciate you all
voting make sure your chips and guaca
totally out the best
the zombie
american woman
[Applause]
i i just nominated i was dominated
i figured i figured cat maybe got back i
could see yeah
no i was not that girl out there no you
were that girl at all no i was like the
nerdy girl
oh okay okay how are you in high school
hello man
your face like lit up like
if you don't sound like this
because you oh yeah i have it he was
interested i was like
don't hurt him not daddy that was a
freshman oh he was a freshman he's a
freshman
oh what was it for homecoming uh prom
homecoming
king oh okay as a freshman damn
you know homecoming is better in prime
because homecoming you get to ride
around that field and the cars and stuff
like that oh yeah yeah
yeah i was too shy though i didn't go on
the parade i was like
i was embarrassed so i didn't do it oh
because yeah they put the
numbers like half time i was like i'm
trying to play a football game
i'm not going on that [ __ ] wagon
[Laughter]
we see you out there brenden good job
good job he's on the field right now
he's playing the game real well
those things are so strange it's weird
can you remember who won
do you know the name of the kids who won
never oh dude not a [ __ ] clue
i don't even know where they're at now
nah yeah it's such a rig
though i'm kudos to that pair and i'm
thinking it's such a rigged system
the most popular kid always wins yeah or
the girl with the biggest
hit but but it's the most popular girl
but the girl the most popular she'll go
up to people she'll never talk to like
hey i'm running against
politics same [ __ ] yeah you're right
it's no different there's paul taken
yeah wait wait wait what were you trying
to say because i said the popular yeah
he's going to vote for the most popular
person but
but she's popular in her crew then she
goes outside her crew
and make the nerves feel good they don't
care about no we had some bad [ __ ]
who were nice people that won
oh where are they like they're like
super they're like our [ __ ]
you know cardi b like everywhere their
tits were big because they had huge
hearts
oh yeah big titties big hearts big
cities
all right next one this is bad news but
it's all over the news right now the
shooting's in atlanta so i'm crazy kid
killed i think eight people most of them
being asian women
asians and two white people right i
think there's uh
it was ford mexican spanish latin name
in there somewhere so
the majority of them were asian he was
going to asian spas
yeah and then according to the police
they're saying that he
had a sexual addiction and he was just
overly tempted or
overly tempted by these women so he to
get rid of his temptation he shot them
just a mentally ill [ __ ] up
yeah now here's why here's the question
for
it's tricky you two in the room not the
white guy and the two black guys for the
two asians in the room
do you think this is racially motivated
because i'll give you my opinion
do you think this is a racial issue it's
definitely racial but do i think
but why is it racial is it racial
because because they're all going to go
to
spawn get happy ending yeah the majority
of people that dominate that industry
are asian
yeah so it's a racial issue for sure so
like so like if he shot up
wall is it a you know let's say shot up
wall street was
which is a majority of white men is it a
racial issue
or is he just shooting wall street
because he's mad that his stocks went
down you don't know
he says his motivation right there dude
that's that's what he's saying but then
what's he saying the cops are saying
that he they told him that it was like
he had a sexual addiction
and then you know these are the women
that he would be attracted to
so that's kind of like he's just crazy
in the head first of all
this is a sick mental individual yeah
the thing is
everything's racial now i think this is
more of a mental health issue so that's
that's the
the thing that i'm like dealing with
right now because there's people i
respect and i follow on instagram
and they're born in america asian
americans and they're pointing to how
this is like
this guy's a racist in this net which
i'm sure
potentially he's a racist but when i see
this he's just a [ __ ]
crazy person he's a crazy person yeah
that killed a place or he killed people
where he would go frequent because he
was attracted to these people correct
right so he has something wrong with his
head so i'm getting too tempted by these
women so i'm going to kill that but i
think it's tough too because asian
americans under attack right now like
that i think that thing
so that 7 500 uh assault i think it's
like
it was like normally a normal year is
like 28 something hundred
asian attacks and anti-asian attacks 7
500 the last year
it's been like up a thousand because you
know obviously
for sure the donald trump kung flu all
that kind of stuff you know
the coronavirus yeah for sure we know
that so that probably like amped up
things but
yes when i saw this i see people that i
respect that are way smarter than me
saying this is crazy straight up this is
just a racial attack yeah i
just feel like i feel like it's it's
it's mostly this guy's just crazy this
specific case
this specific case got it it's like the
shooter at the uh
the aurora century movie theater the guy
who shot everyone on the dark knight
most people he shot were white some were
black
so that's just a crazy guy who shot
people
you know would you classify this kind of
tragedy with the
world cl uh tragedies as far as like the
dylan ruth who went in that black church
and killed those people or no that's
right
that's racial okay that's racial because
he we know for a fact was a white spot
that was his motivation
and he went to a black church because he
knew black people were going to be there
okay what about
with the purpose of killing black people
because they were black
are you talking about orlando what about
the orlando with the gays orlando one
that he killed because they were gay but
he no
that guy was also gay oh he was saying
he's mad that he's gay his mentality i
can't remember but
that guy's not gay he wasn't no he was
anti-gay
the orlando shooting where he were like
murdered yeah
no he went to that club because they
were gay oh i think i heard something
about him being closeted too like he
used to frequent there
that sounds like something i thought
yeah yeah i remember hearing that
but his motive was the kill because they
were gay oh so he went from his mental
okay i got you so he's
probably like a projection thing it's
crazy they're all crazy they're all
mentally ill
some are mentally ill and racist and
some are mentally ill
and i i think he would have shot people
with their asian
white like if he would have went to a
white parlor and was attracted to whites
he would have killed whites got you
because a black party would have killed
blacks okay all right it is a weird
touchy thing but yeah when i see people
post about that
i feel like when they're continuing to
say like this is a racial racial thing
it's
it's more perpetuating more this us
against them kind of thing i don't wanna
i don't wanna see that yeah all right or
whatever
it's such a shame though dude you said
you had an opinion on it that you wanted
he just
that was my opinion man remember i just
did a whole rant on it yeah
that's the opinion yeah uh
so on a lighter note about asian steven
yoon
first asian american nominator for best
uh actor
um
bro you were so diverse this is crazy
bro oh i know i know but
it's a movie about korean immigrants who
are originally in california the guy
always wanted to be a farmer so he moves
into the middle
of the country somewhere in the midwest
tries to open up a farm
and it kind of goes through him and his
relationship with his family
after he like forced them out of their
comfort zone
and he's korean right yeah yes yeah he
was from now walking dead mm-hmm
yeah walking there walking yesterday i
have no desire to see it but
hopefully when's the world you want to
check it out no i might check out
i've heard amazing things too but i
still haven't seen it really my brother
tom it's like one of the best oh really
then i'll check it out yeah i'll i'll
watch it i'll check it out
you think he's going to win no he won no
no no nobody
it's the first time ever though oh i
thought he won my bad no it's all good
bro
uh you think he's going to win though i
haven't seen the movie
i got to watch first yeah it's also the
oscar so who [ __ ] knows of that
committee oh yeah because he might win
he's not white
but he also got your man who uh just
passed away chad with balls man he's
just winning oh chatter win
yeah for a variety of reasons
all right did you hear this uh kirk
franklin yeah kirk
talking to his son yeah but if someone
was coming at him crazy i don't know
let me hear it by the way this is like a
family thing so i'm sure
yeah he's like a full-grown man okay
hold on there's some family stuff though
that's what i'm saying it's family stuff
[Applause]
for one he said he like to keep his
business private family businesses
of course does his son put on trying to
put his dad on blast like oh you think
you're you know this guy's so perfect
and all that look at how he threat
threatened cheat uh treat his son
and stuff like that i'm like man this is
it's not again get your skinny
[ __ ] ass back out of the
goddamn way before i put my foot up your
ass
this son must do something i will break
your neck if you ever disrespect me
this is this between him at the waiting
room yes what are we gonna cancel
it has nothing to do with us that's not
that's not our family that's exactly
that's not that has nothing to do with
us
so i don't give a [ __ ] the funny thing
about this is plies here's
applies
he goes that was me not my dog on the
phone that was me
because if you ever hear plies on
instagram he sounds just like that
oh yeah he looks just like him yeah he
looks like him dude yeah yeah
he looks just like him like this this is
a random thing that he did
real real quick i had a conversation
with my home girl about 10-15 minutes
ago
she want to get all the surgery done she
want to get a butt done
a chest done a stomach flat a way small
i'm not saying justin what reminds me of
justin logan
do you know what you're getting all the
dog food you've been attracted she said
no
i said [ __ ] with some [ __ ]
money
that's the only people you eat
speaking facts
oh it's so funny he got rid of his
grills right yeah he got his teeth now a
lot of rappers starting to do
yeah the vineyards that's a good look
yeah they're growing up
well these young rappers as well i think
it's i think it's just a [ __ ]
teeth are already [ __ ] high
maintenance as it is i think they
realize how ridiculous
yes i'm still going to get a grill no
matter what you're gonna get a grill but
yeah the one
i thought you're just gonna get the one
they're going back
i thought you could get that one gold
what they're gonna get the one goal oh
yeah
i tell you i lost my [ __ ] two oh cap
you're gonna get a cat yeah i got a room
i got a root canal yeah and uh which
wasn't bad
uh and the cap fell out or whatever so
i'm gonna get a gold cap you know what
i'm saying
that's tight yeah sick yeah don't cancel
that man no
i mean that's her family yeah that's
family [ __ ] if my son came at me crazy
has your dad ever said some wild [ __ ] to
you nah not like that
no not like that were you about to ask
me if my dad
your stepdad are saying
is
crazy [ __ ] to you um no my asian parents
never really
talk they hit yeah yeah yeah chan you
just hit
yeah straight up just hit no words
straight huh yeah they hit
they don't have to say anything you'll
see they're looking their eyes and
you're like
[ __ ] it's over i can see it in your eyes
what's this
why is this a current event why is this
a current event cool why not no
why why what he's doing why it's not
yeah why is it not a kurt event but
because
listen we are let me see i don't know
the audience don't like sport talk let's
just get started
you don't know what the audience are you
guys trust me
i got to see it you know it's just a is
it like a you know hilarious reaction to
this air ball
[Applause]
his friend started laughing at him oh
[ __ ] watch steph curry watch that first
he said
did they win that game at least yeah we
blew them out by 30. oh yeah yeah
[ __ ] well you won you could but we
didn't we didn't choose
i thought cruz would cruz was dope
though right yeah he's dope he's bro
he's a good player
but i understand why we chose him to
shoot the free throws
arguing with jake he was like who you
want he's like who you want to shoot the
free throw
lebron lebron can shoot free throws no
not this season oh never mind just
kidding and that's pretty much it though
lebron james because it
and he is a billion dollar contract with
nikes so
it is why is uh boston specifically is
that like
their top five most valuable teams out
of any sport okay
part owner but i don't they didn't say
how much uh
how much you just own some shares yeah
so it's probably like minority owner
but you know like uh [ __ ] what's
named uh
bill maher for uh that you know he does
the yeah he owns the mats
he owns ownership in the mat
damn so ownership just means like
because there's a jc you gotta have big
boy money you gotta have big jason
because if you have ownership you're
talking billions and hundreds and
hundreds of millions oh bill maher's got
that
i got that big one big boy money i
didn't know that
one of my friends i met from uh usc his
dad owns a part of the warriors
stupid room like what does that what do
you do when you're a owner do you just
own a share do you have like any say in
what happened
no you have no say oh okay so it's kind
of like just holding us having a
think about how much it's so valuable
because oh the value there's only a few
people in the world can own teams and
then
the value of like the golden state wars
is through the [ __ ] roof
so i'm sure he could sell shares at any
moment [ __ ] bank
would you do that if you could i wish
dude yeah so hard
if you had all the money in the world
what team would you buy
that's a great question right for your
bills huh you would not
but
[Laughter]
well the most valuable teams are like
the cowboys the lakers
the yankees yeah red sox is up there
what about soccer team yeah soccer i
think manchester united is number one
yeah oh my
god trying to make money man just
manchester united oh no man
manchester is the big one man city's the
smaller like as far as like money wise
liverpool's big liverpool arsenal
arsenal's big
those premier leagues make yeah
damn for real what about the uh i'd
rather i'd rather own
a partnership in the ufc because i know
that sport
oh okay i know how to market and stuff
get help yeah that means baseball i'm
like i don't know
yeah i'm pretty sure lebron let his
handlers just deal with that he don't
know anything about baseball
oh it's such a good investment though
because boss and red sox dude
do you you so his investors are like
pretty much handling
like a lot of that work yeah he doesn't
have to like do much he just
puts his money games on it but they're
like there's an opportunity for you
to buy into the boston red sox this is
how much it's going to be there's only a
couple of
sockets like barcelona is that is that a
big one they're huge
so there's yeah go to top five most
valuable franchises in
sports sports it's yeah i'll i'll before
you even show it it's
yankees no particular order but i think
manchester
is number one yankees lakers
dallas cowboys and then another premier
league team what do we got
oh i thought the knicks up there dallas
yankees i said
lakers warriors real madrid patriots
barcelona
those are the top dallas cowboys number
one at 5.5
billion jared it's weird didn't it weird
because they're americans
who was number one yeah exactly but they
haven't won nothing
and they stay on what is it and how
about the knicks oh i missed i said
awful but then but it's all they're all
so big yeah yeah but the knicks is
always but they're good this year but
they always been
in that room of the best sports team
but think how many people have money in
the world it's so hard to get ownership
in the team
you don't see a lot of guys as like
having shares in like what you said
those premier leagues like barcelona
or arsenal you don't know who owns some
[ __ ]
yeah but real madrid barcelona look at
that out of the 10
uh what do we got manchester united one
two three
three are uh basketball new york giants
most the most is basketball dude yeah
uh you got one two three well it's kind
of
count even because the couch you had
three and then you got yeah it's really
basketball football premier league so
why
i mean no baseball i don't know i guess
just the yankees at five billion number
two
so wait the golden state warriors did
that not pop until like they became that
yeah that popularity so that's what you
add in the stadium which adds value just
have that new arena so that helps
like all these things all those tech
guys broncos three bill i'm getting with
the broncos
you again with the broncos [ __ ] yes now
how many now how many people are
in like not many not many like usually
there's one like pat bowling
uh-huh the bowling family owns the
broncos the cronkies
and the crafts on the jerry jones with
the cowboys yeah it's usually one guy
who's jay-z is it jake oh you're talking
about brooklyn he's part of brooklyn
yeah i think nelly's is too nelly is
part of uh
i know you're talking st louis not he's
something yeah but look at this
investment so the new york knicks
whoever bought that paid 300 million in
1997.
it's worth 4.6 billion now the guy the
guy uh he's in the band the owner uh
is it every everyone's hates him um the
guy get he got uh
you know what i'm talking about he's in
the band [ __ ] she said nickelback is
that it nah man god they gonna kill me
uh just type in new york knicks oh no uh
um
not the google dolls um foo foo fighter
no bigger than that
uh you know who he is bro white guy has
has like uh pearl jam
no huge no just go from philly
bruce springsteen no no he's not from
philly look at it
owner of what the new york knicks
it's my
[Applause]
he's just a piece of [ __ ] i was a
football team
philadelphia oh ooh that's a bummer my
bad
yeah i don't see it oh he owns an arena
team yeah well are the arena teams still
popping out bro they're doing the
[ __ ] rattlers
were the ones yup utah blaze shot the
utah blaze i played for them
you did it yeah oh dude i've been to
those arena football games
i used to go to the rally bruh they are
so lit oh [ __ ] damn i like them you're
in a real football game though
yeah i fell asleep it was the cardinals
versus the steelers
oh no that was against the falcons and
we just had got our we just had got our
stadium oh wow
yeah i fell asleep were you drinking at
the time was i i was a drunk
i'm drunk right now
[Laughter]
he had to go to court tomorrow he looked
at that fridge oh yeah
i was saying last night when they
brought the dessert i said you know
denzel feels in flight yeah when he
walks in the hotel room in that
refrigerator
when that dessert came out like i feel
like denzel is like
[Laughter]
all right kids uh think boy saint patty
day sale through
sunday the entire site is 17
off except for the uh think boy nation
stuff which is sold out
on that everything is 17 off we're
talking thick boy smiley face we're
talking
the thick boy sweats the specialized
gear hats
water bottles short sleeve hoodies
tie-dye everything is 17
off so get you some man thickboy.com
spokane we will see you this thursday
friday saturday we click on the link are
we sold out yet
the new shows chin so all shows are sold
out except for
uh late show thursday and early show
oh try clicking on that seven o'clock
i can't buy anything so i'm guessing
click on the uh if it won't let yeah i
won't let you buy now click on the
saturday 9 31. dog they want to add a
third show on friday
hey dude what y'all thinking yeah i
think everything's sold out well spokane
sorry we had a show so there's not much
else i can do without my [ __ ] dick
falling off
uh we will see this weekend spokane and
then
next week we are in miami there are
tickets left for miami florida florida
or sorry miami improv thursday friday
saturday that is next thursday friday
saturday with the miami improv
get you some
all right guys love you have a good
weekend have a good weekend
malik b rolly boy off right
and i got the pesto on my socks
nice
gold chain you know what i'm saying i
tried that was a little tough
the swagger was off it wasn't yeah you
started off
i started off flat you know i don't know
how to pick that up keep it simple
keep it simple bobbing weave to the
instrumental
[Laughter]
uh what's up troll lazy man phones over
everything and we got a teddy
uh i don't know how to say these fours
top a's or something like that
you know what they're do you know what
they're called uh
taipei yeah c-a-t-a-u
i don't know but hello shout out to my
boy uh ryan lacroix
who uh hooked it up with these man you
know he found these for me he knew i was
looking for him for a long time
so shout out to that dude for that one
oh [ __ ] hey dude what's
up daddy just check my ass though
it's st patrick's day oh who don't have
green i'm going to pinch you
wait is it today yeah i'm going to pinch
something big boy saint patrick's day
sale going on right now
see you uh see you spokane see you
tomorrow yeah